do i play andre and then work up to
alexandra
yeah okay let's play andrea
um we'll make it a challenge how about
okay
what to play let's play e4 let's be
aggressive maybe i'll play on
gambit type thing or ponziani
i thought andrea plays the french okay
let's let's play ponziani
main line it's like the most popular
line so far
queen b3 eric gingerty cozy
just like this position very cozy pieces
can develop
i actually don't think i have any ginger
tea currently
i'm drinking some green tea right now
nice way to to wake up
start the day
queen d7 i mean it's not a blender but
it's not a great like positional move
um let's develop normally
okay i'll play you three green tea oh
wait that's that's 2500 bits that's like
grand master level
amount of bits i think you ave it on
yeah the green tea bits have to put that
towards the green tea fund
i'll show um it probably will be
slightly invisible
um yeah actually it's not too bad
this is what i'm drinking actually honey
ginseng
um yeah so not manuka honey
it's nice it's like lightly sweet
uh okay let's play this move
white's slightly better here but it
might take like a lot of work to
actually win
this position
um
okay let's slowly build up on the king
side
yeah andrea being very protective of the
the d-pawn
oh just do i just go for the kill
i think i do
okay that was very generous
this is giving me confidence very nice
oh she forced my bishop and pawn
i feel like i can just take here and
keep having fun this is discover check
and i'll play knife seven next move
with the the fork knight let's go
i probably don't need to take the rook
like queen h7
okay maybe now i take the rook
this position is so fun i can play e4
and if takes like i fork again
this is so much fun it's almost meeting
too
i feel kind of bad but okay it's this is
robot andrea so
i mean she probably still has some
emotion but
wait am i mating i have to calculate
here
check here then 96 and then mate
you sure got me yeah i sure did check
and then meet
three months on twitch oh it's not neat
wait oh this is me check check me okay
let's go thank you wickendwolf
wait what oh the rook's pinned
oh that's not fair
i i tried to do like the hikaru
impressive pre-movement
but rook raka f8 is illegal
okay i guess i'll have to be more
patient
oh okay this is wait
these bots are so good at like surviving
when they shouldn't be surviving i have
three pieces but i don't see the horse
mate i'll just play king h1
okay it's gonna end eventually
and bishop d7 okay check check
when do you think stafford gambit two
will be released
so i forgot um i thought i was mating
i thought this was the only legal move i
forgot this was possible
it's a good thing that pawn didn't have
a chance to promote
okay what a game
that loss was chat's fault yeah when in
doubt blame it on chat
oh chad is doing that thing where they
they make these faces
what does this face oh d
colin yeah this face of trauma
probably
anyway do i do i work my way up to
alexandra
next spot oh
let's have an exciting game okay i'll
play the same opening i think she's
going to play a french
yeah what do i play against the french
let's play an ortho schnapp wait what
queen h4 want to move
it's actually kind of a cool
i guess when you play the french you
could do this
it's not right but it's um
it's clever she wants to mate me in like
two more moves
let's defend a pong yeah
let's develop
okay now now the moves are looking a bit
more reasonable
of
just keep developing
ooh sipping emperor's cloud and mist
green tea
that's actually you can get that at
starbucks
but i think it's through tivana i
remember having that for the first time
in chiang mai thailand i went to a
starbucks wanted hot tea
and they were promoting that it's really
good nice um
nice kind of soothing green tea
okay pawns are a little bit ridiculous
but also
magnificent looking oh
there goes my pawn okay
i have to treat every mistake as a
gambit
how do i wait let's
let's get the king safe eventually or
not
i'm just losing or no i have to play
bishop f1
i'm losing this pawn
oh actually so if i castle
queen takes e4 bishop d3 oh it doesn't
trap the queen because queen here
but i have this move
i might be trapping the queen
wow f5
it's getting spicy
i guess i should
wait a minute
i might just get crushed here let's try
this though
um
and she's hurting me what's castle
but maybe okay maybe now the queen or
the knight is lost
here we go okay life is better now
oh except she wants to make me on c2
so let's let's play rook d2 or rook g2
or queen g2 maybe i'll just trade queens
also creating the battery so queen g2 is
forced
now i have the bishop hair
okay could be a long grind
why not rook g1 yeah rook g1 earlier in
many cases would have lost f3
would have almost trapped the queen but
i don't think there was ever a point
where i had the chance
okay
oh it's bishop for three pawns actually
so i think in this case i want to keep
both bishops bishop hair is really nice
um let's play this move
oh i was about to blunder my rook uh
let's not be too generous
i'm playing the bots i feel like make me
play worse
let's play this move also i should
touch base okay so botas live is live so
their username makes sense now um
i think very soon we'll uh we'll
probably hop on call to discuss
the details develop the king
so i'm just gonna try and win as quickly
as possible
which might be difficult
good evening eric good evening
orbis how's it going thanks for
resubbing
i'm getting out played here this is not
pleasant
the spawn's weak
um play this move b5
this move
okay making some progress this pawn is
now weak
let's go
if i trade i think this is winning
yeah because i have a very active king
come around with the bishop
yeah this is winning
it was a cool meeting idea
okay
let's go let's go
okay i feel accomplished i took work
that took 61 moves